[Música]
de aprovechar y disfrutar lo que sucede
todo
maravilloso y aburrido como
y todos los tipos de momentos que han
presentado desde sumatoria
con
todo lo positivo que se puede crear
voy a sacar el segundo bebé a aportar
nuestro propósito con nuestra razón es
que requiere ser construido día a día
toda nuestra energía para poder resistir
para permanecer lo que es más importante
uno
de todos
visualizar
porque vamos a afrontar sea lo que sea
lo que vaya a ocurrir
el inicio de la humanidad el hombre
siempre ha luchado por estar
al principio a través de eso
en cualquier instrumento que le perdí
acercarse
ansiado y miel
fabulosa la vida sin sufrimiento
todos estaban muy cerca ese sentimiento
lo primero que hice en hacer llorar casi
todo
preparamos durante meses para ese
momento
y estamos en control para expresar con
todo
ah
en ese instante cuando comienza
y muy comúnmente
multiplicar en magnificarlo pero no en
controlar muchísimo mente aprovecharlo
siendo absolutamente claro la vida sin
dolor
directamente
al crecimiento sin hundido en el dolor
maravilloso
que llevaría a un mundo perdido
durante cuatro días
esta montaña mucho frío
es fuerte sólido muy confiado
pesado
avanzamos actitud nada
cambiaría radicalmente
de que hay una vez
incontables no
no podemos seguir así
el camino se va a complicar aún más que
hacemos regresamos y perdernos o
continuamos nivel
a la hora de regresar
también la forma de avanzar porque para
mí que era el único que no podía caminar
que apoyaron sobre el ojo de una mula
la salvadora
apoyados sobre paso lento y abajo
con un saco de papas
y largas sobre las horas que se
convirtieron
y otra vez
y bueno yo solo decidían entrar
y mucho
hay también vómito
pero hay también sobre silla de montar
y hago
en su potencial para que cualquier
persona que lo tiene utilizará
las diversidades
no bastaba que una vez que muchas veces
mucho
la vida y al poco tiempo
regalo de amarre literalmente a un
campeón de windsurf para hacer una
delegación médica
mis piernas
complicadas
y grandes corrientes en medio del mar en
peñasco
hay 120 metros
en américa sentados a una bolsa con una
línea caliente como una sopa
independiente
me está permitiendo ser
y decidir lo que quiero llegar a ser
y realidad
y todo lo que podía
está convirtiendo una carga para mucho
s
valente
ahora bien
tal y como es sin deformar
de una manera consciente o inconsciente
y boca abajo
50 2
impensable para una persona que no diese
además interés en el mundo perfecto
mis amigos
muchas otras personas
festín de vida
porque estaba empezando
y sin nombrar el sentido del viento
entender como ese sentimiento que
aparece en nuestras vidas cada cuadra
y
y aprovechado
de las vivencias más terribles y
trascendentales en inglés
pero sobrevivió a cuatro campos
auschwitz y de acabó y lo hizo sin
perder su dignidad el inversor
o sea no su experiencia en su
sufrimiento para darle sustento
científico
y regalar
aceptar lo que pasa e incluir he llevado
podía ver todo sin aprovechar nada
y directamente un vacío en came
si escogemos el foco de atención y
orientar nuestros recursos personales en
el momento dado hacen potencial
operación que tenga cualquiera un
elemento de lo que estamos viviendo cero
difícil desear en ese escenario
y no es algo temporal que fortalece
directamente
está llegando y empezamos dibujando lo
que estamos escondiendo lo que tiene hoy
en llamar sea programa es de cada quien
la vida
más tarde esos tres pasos esenciales
i
en el momento
qué
mi lugar
[Música]
y siempre porque cada momento diferencia
y lo más importante
[Música]
y aún